all right booyah drink is a best-selling
author and New York Times columnist
Frank Bruni is over here
great pleasure to me - okay well Frank
I've wanted to hear for a long time but
not more than lately because you have
written two columns that were such music
to my ears the first one was called I'm
a white man hear me out
what about this new phenomenon that as a
white man somehow we're just just
qualified for being in the debate and
somebody's got to speak up for the white
men without the tiki torches I mean we'd
still have something yeah absolutely
yeah all right we'll talk about it all
right though though I wrote that because
there are a lot of debates that happen
these days I mean you've listened to
them I think you've commented on them
where you get the message that if you
are not part of minority group if you
haven't suffered in that exact way you
can't possibly be empathetic and you
can't possibly understand and I think
that's one of the things right now that
divides us I agreed with just about
everything Reverend Jackson said I'm a
white person and that needs to be
acknowledged that I'm not the enemy he's
not saying I am but often you know you
go on Twitter it's it's of course easy
to talk about Twitter because it's such
a flea market you go on Twitter and you
see this sort of oppression Olympics
where if you are not as addressed as I
am right then don't tell me you can be
on my side what I said in that column
I'm a white man and so you know a lot of
people say you have nothing to say I'm
also a gay man right so that brings
about this assumption that I have some
experience but you know what my being a
white man thank you though we're seeing
each other after the show
[Laughter]
why is something change in you know I
mean I I am white and I need to be
cognizant of the fact that certain
privileges utterly unearned have come
with that right I am gay and so I
understand perhaps what it means to be
an outsider neither one of those things
tells you anything about my character
right my character is what matters not
what category I fit into a category
isn't a credential so you quote mark
Lilla yeah okay who is Mark Lola if he's
at Columbia University Professors yeah
okay I should know him better if you
know him okay
so and he wrote this great thing he kind
of summed it up he said we're kind of
confronted with this demand
you must understand my experience and
you can't understand my experience which
does put us in a crazy position that we
can't possibly fulfill it gives you no
real estate to stand on okay so the
other one the other column you wrote
that I really loved was it called these
campus inquisitions must stop and I've
been on this page for many many years
I've note yes and and I was myself
disinvited to speak at Berkeley before
they re invited me and it just seems to
me like what you learn at college for
maybe $60,000 a year is that if you can
find anyone anywhere who is less
sensitive than you you can get them
fired because the best person is always
the one who censors the most things and
this is this is tearing up this country
apart I think I agree I agree well I
wrote that column specifically that
something happened at Evergreen State
College I think maybe some people
understand don't know what happened
there but there was open right yes there
was a there's something that happens
every year they're called the day of
remembrance and it's a day devoted to
racial healing and usually black
students voluntarily leave campus to
have discussions and all that about that
sort of stuff this year someone
suggested that maybe white students
should leave instead and a white biology
professor said you know I don't I don't
like the sounds of that that feels to me
like someone's suggesting segregation
now you can agree or disagree with what
he said what came back at him for simply
kind of
you know putting that out there for
debate what came back at him was that he
was a racist but he was a white
supremacist this was shouted at him you
can see the videos on YouTube I'm he had
to stay away from campus for a while he
has to be allowed to bring up a point
that's utterly worthy of debate without
confronting those sorts of slurs and
when I wrote about this interestingly
one of the one of the responses I got
from a reader was so many of the black
students that evergreen have experiences
of suffering and all that why are you
wasting your sympathy on a white man and
literally the reader wrote he's white
he'll be fine that's the kind of
thinking that I think is so divisive and
destructive and that we have to do away
with and it's also the kind of thinking
that got White's which are still 69% of
the country I think to vote like a
minority in 2016 I think because they
were many of them felt like they were
being treated that way which is insane
because they're not yeah but I mean this
is a big problem the Democratic Party
has to face many Trump voters were
absolutely out-and-out racists but some
I think were frustrated with these
things that we're describing right now I
think there are a lot of people out
there of good heart you know who want to
be able to have a conversation about all
of this without feeling like they're
stepping on eggshells all the time and I
think right now we have a world exactly